we're on online yep we're on the
Internet yeah we are Dan yeah welcome to
the real rejects hi I'm Ryan right
welcome to the real rejects I'm Dan
severed today we're gonna check out the
extended III 2015 gameplay demo
Uncharted 4 a thief's end this game we
already caught the first seven minutes
of it there for now there's more which
is awesome there's an extra eight we're
not gonna watch the first seven again
because you could already watch a video
of us watching that if you want to let's
go from where we left off we'll start
exactly at seven minutes remember that
he's yeah yeah yeah
hey hey
you're gonna see the aftermath video cuz
it cut the black yeah yeah because he
did that and then he was good right here
right here
he's wakeboarding Wow Wow
is a clay balls your arm
I don't know any go down while he's
doing this oh wow does look cool they
can drink such a goddamn badass I know
I'm just like
now it's really what you do it yes Wow
this guy has incredible strength
some ways this is the most cinematic Oh
Hey
you kidding burger
right
Wow he's impenetrable
[ __ ] I love all the little movie
things you can do
everyone that's working I know
get closer
okay Sam get in the car
so right daddy's Nathan Drake oh my god
ah I wish this was most of the game get
out of here
nah No
what John
oh nice sick got him in the like
ah
oh my god
three
that's funny dude
absolutely
it's scary
whoa
oh what a cool game yeah good yeah just
love the best goddamn video games of all
time
oh there's more there's more because I'm
like utterly speechless right now it's
just slow down so cinematic right
looks like a baby I hope please I don't
know how much more my heart today but I
think the coast is clear
from dares called essentia it's not like
a simple cipher for God in Liberty he's
there Danny bought all the paradise
references it is the mystic see you two
made it out okay
way better than okay you found the
battalion liver liver wedding Battaglia
seems Avery farm of the legendary pirate
colony eyes warm up a pirate utopia
really okay what about the treasure yes
so sexy isn't Drake sexy
property we saw everyone look so good
they kept it all in one common treasure
dolly
okay so where is this Tommy
pirate sanctuary right here
that Island just northeast of Kings Bay
your FS are copying us yeah well by the
time Bray figures it out
we'll be well on our way to live Italian
treasure this is good around our house
the Malaysia job going he sure seems
like you're a hair off course he is in
[ __ ] trouble his balls are gonna be
owned baby were worse yeah they're gonna
be owned literally she's gonna rip them
off yeah and she's gonna own them she
could sell it if she wants cuz she is
now legal owner of his balls so Elena's
back of course youth you have course
she's well um the game has just
solidified more of what we already said
before and what we will continue to keep
saying I will argue that it actually
took what we said like from the last
like where we ended and I just kind of
like on top of it as I was watching my
initial reaction is this might be one of
my favorite games out of the e3 it looks
like you'll be one of my favorite games
of all time like it makes me want to go
back and just play all three just
straight through in one sitting
I'm buying the duel pack of Part one and
two oh are you yes oh yeah part three
then when this comes out yeah I'll be
ready yeah I'll be ready dude [ __ ]
games and crap I know I played demos
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel by the way never said I was a
big gamer but you guys keep treating me
like I am one so don't get mad at me
when I don't know much anyway we're
gonna tell you that you should subscribe
to the real rejects today mm-hmm and
then afterwards you can head over to
that cyber channel where I did a wrap-up
of the three big major conferences in
video and gave you opinions and stuff
it's great what conferences Nintendo a
Microsoft the only three the e3
conferences
you should have clarify the e3
conferences I did a video on it go watch
it
I make funnies or life is it like it is
like like poop on the mouth you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine where we get enough followers
we can get product placement
oh you for things such as mystery boxes
mystery boxes are great would you like
to know what's in this box I would tell
you but I will be considered a horrible
influence if I did show you what was in
this box it's a soul it's [ __ ] Pulp
Fiction [ __ ] it's full fiction it's just
bright gold mm-hmm watch I'll show damn
what's in this box
never mind on a slope no but it sure
makes it feel good doesn't it dance